dow
surges above 30 000 for the first time
as investors
cheer transition to biden administration
what a nice title that article sets as
investors cheer to biden administration
u.s stocks jumped on tuesday
as a start of the transition to biden
administration spurred another rotation
to cyclical stocks
dow jones industrial roads about 30 000
for the first time river boeing
led the benchmark index higher followed
by chevron and jp morgan the new record
caps a benchmark rebound from the start
of the pandemic when the overwhelming
bearishness dragged the index as low as
eighteen thousand two thirteen in march
so why
adam are we over thirty thousand
with the dow i mean this is exciting
stuff i'm not going to get into the
political do i think this is
all biden not clearly not do i think
this is
a lot of trump some of biden some of
janet yellen some of the people being
uh obviously stimulus this is this is
this was how much of this you think is
trump biden
uh uh vaccine oh vaccine for sure
what would you put at the top of the
list why we're at 30 000. why we're at
specifically thirty thousand first and
foremost i would put the
trillions of dollars that we pumped into
the economy over the last
six months for sure that's the only one
i mean number two
so so it's fake is what you're saying is
it's fake that it's over thirty thousand
i'm saying that it's a little inflated
inflated okay a little bit yeah i'm
saying stimulus
i'm sorry i'm saying uh vaccine
clearly if there were no news of a
vaccine let's not forget
coven's still here and it's actually
getting more rampant and widespread
throughout the country
i mean they said in the fall and in the
winter the numbers would go up and
that's exactly what happened but the
fact that there's they
who's they who said they people have
been they
everyone the media left and right okay
um experts fauci whoever you want to put
on that list
they've been saying watch out for a
second wave we've united
we've heard this a million times um does
trump get credit
sure does biden you know not spooking
the market and picking
super leftist progressives bernie
sanders and elizabeth warren to be on
his cabinet
and going with a little more sensible
moderate veterans like janet yellen
get credit sure um do vaccines
uh pfizer moderna astrazeneca get credit
i don't think this is a one-man show but
most importantly thing so if we want to
give credit credit can go all around
what i
want to convey to the audience is
beginning of the year i'm not sure if
you're a big stock market guy i'm i'm
not like a massive stock market guy but
that's i'm i'm i'm with it i believe in
the stock market and the power
of compound interest i'm a huge advocate
of it
january where was the dow that was at 28
29
000. somewhere hovering around that
number march where did the dow hit march
2014
18 18 2 ridiculous where are we now in
freaking thanksgiving 30 frickin
thousand so all of my interests
exactly what trump said was gonna happen
okay
yeah so trump said exactly that the
dow's gonna go about 30
000 before the end of the year and they
said you're out of your mind well he
said that in april
okay yeah well he called it yeah so i
mean but i wonder what i'm wondering is
how much of it is
how much of it is vaccine how much of it
is biden how much of it is trump
that's what i wonder because you know
it's very hard to say
well it's because of trump really
because you know what we said
after uh uh you know trump got elected
and he won and hillary clinton conceded
what happened to the market the next
week two weeks
boom it went up and they said that when
trump got elected the stock market would
crumble
and it went up it went up yeah so so
what i'm trying to say to you is so
if if they say the credit is trump the
market went up
okay but now this time around
they say biden one now it's obviously
not over with but if you're if trump is
sitting there saying listen we're going
to work with you and start sharing
resources
they're kind of heading the direction of
saying we're willing to share resources
now he's still tweeting away saying 92
percent of the
survey from newsmax says that i
shouldn't concede and i shall still here
but it's newsmax newsmac is of course
zero credibility
not zero credibility newsmax is gonna be
one-sided it's not about zero
credibility it's like cnn's gonna be
one-sided msnbc is gonna be one set it's
not zero credibility
what side they're gonna say it's like
what are your kids gonna say about you
all good things about you that's my dad
right so but at the same time
market goes to 30 thou
after biden gets becomes whatever you
want to call a president-elect
what is what are the investors saying
are they saying they're optimistic
because it it doesn't make any sense
because the senate's not over with and
anytime all three is on once like the
point i'm trying to make
so many things are going on where trends
don't add up right now
when i mean trends don't add up you got
a guy that goes campaigning no one shows
up guys are showing up to honk the horn
50 people are showing up another guy
who's showing up to rallies 60 000
people are showing up 25 000 people have
to be kicked out
and the other guy wins it's very weird
and he breaks obama's record he breaks
everybody
how the hell does that happen and then
now we
we don't have fully results on who's the
president we don't have full results on
what's going to happen in georgia
there's so many uncertainties what are
investors excited about
what are they exciting there's no
certain answers right now so so here
would be my
my question is kind of a different angle
to view it and i don't know if there's a
way to analyze what these figures
are right but if it goes from 28 29 000
to
to you know south of 20 000 and then in
a matter of months goes back later i
would be real curious to know
what the figure of 401k and low level
you know just regular
uh investors you know what what the
percentage of
whale size market share uh owners have
now versus six months ago versus 12
months ago
right so there was a huge transfer of
wealth
you know from from my perspective and
i'd be curious as to as to whose hands
it went from because it seems like
the average everyday citizen got out of
or or lost their ass in a lot of these
markets and then now
it was picked back up by uh by bigger
guys that that's that's what i would i
would suspect that there's
at least some element of that too do you
mean that the average citizen lost their
ass
so so like the you know people that see
the stock market
you know starting to crumble and they
get rid of whatever and then the stock
market goes below 20 000 and now all of
a sudden
uh some of these guys i mean there was a
one story of a
of a hedge fund guy in new york that
made like six billion dollars in in 18
hours or something like that because he
it goes down bill ackman so it goes down
to 18 and now
these other bigger players scoop up all
this you know all this uh market share
at that
uh you know at a much lower price and
now it's back up to 29. again i'm not
necessarily insinuating anything i would
be curious to see if there is a
disparity or a huge contrast between
what it was
in terms of of the the breakdown the
percentage of how many different people
owned
certain shares at 28 000 a year ago
what it went down to it at six months
ago and then what it is now and see what
kind of difference there is because i i
would bet that there's a difference
no valid questions uh just a couple
points
um 55 percent of americans own some sort
of stock
so flip a coin whether this even relates
to you or not
meaning you know wall street if you're
investing wall street you got some stock
if you're on main street
you don't you don't have anything 401k
stock what have you um you know you
brought up a point that i
actively listened to about not letting
your emotions get the best of you
when it comes to guns and listening to
the facts
if you're an investor out there and you
panicked and freaked and let your
emotions get the best of you i agree
in february and march and you sold many
like pat
said that he knew many people wealthy
people that freaked out and sold
six months later the joke's on you buddy
i learned this lesson in 2008
when every i mean i just entered the
financial services world in 2006 2007.
i j i went from a broke as a joke party
club guy
to i made six figures at 27 years old i
was like holy [ __ ] what do i do all this
money
and i developed a save that money
mentality because i saw everything
around me crumbling crumbling crumbling
crumbling
and then people were asking how much
money did you lose in 2008 i was like
all over nothing because i didn't have
any freaking money but i rode the obama
10-year
bull run and then which you know
obviously trump bull run
you know coupled that and i learned my
lesson that
if you're going to invest this is a
long-term game if you're
like a famous line is you only lose if
you jump off the roller coaster
the the roller coaster is going to go up
it's going to go down it's going to go
left it's right you're going to get
whiplash and all that
you only lose if you jump off so
you know i'm very you know 80 20 stocks
to bonds but as you get older to all our
older listeners out there
i would encourage you to just take a
more you know balanced approach and not
have eighty percent stock and freak out
that your retirement's gone
have a little more stabilizing force and
100 minus your age 100 minus your age is
the formula
100 minus your age okay so if you're 40
what are you saying
60 equities 60 40 i'm a little more
aggressive i'm still 80 20.
it's fine that's fine but point is 80 20
20 40
whatever your age matters your age is a
thing so the bill ackman thing that you
brought up he placed a bet you know this
is the you know the big short movie we
all saw that
you know he basically shorted the
economy he told people that hell was
coming
he made a big bet on the economy he's
doing another one right now we covered
that earlier
um what's my point what's my point here
you talked about
emotions i let the emotions get the best
of me in the gun debate
i try not to let my emotions get the
best of me when it comes
to the economy and the stock market and
and my money
so we love you being emotional adam it's
just you know you're an emotional human
being
and you're not a robot and we love you
for it so that's just
that's all there is to it man so but uh
yeah i mean 30 000. we'll see what's
going to happen there i mean the
question now becomes
over the next four years is it going to
hover around 30
000 with the biden administration or is
it going to get close to 40 thousand
where do you think it's going to go
what's more likely
going let's hear about it from the
comments what's more likely going to 40
or hovering around 30k
in my opinion if this vaccine comes out
and there's a one more stimulus package
that happens you know in january
i think we're going to enter the roaring
20s i really do i think
vaccines here covets in the rearview
mirror
whether you agree with biden politically
or not
what's changing i think to go into
roaring twenties i think the kind of
question okay
what is the difference okay so a couple
things yeah i think obama
set this trajectory after 2008. obama
didn't set a trajectory you have to
realize when you keep saying obama set a
trajectory
obama came right after
a stimulus package no no no recession
you mean
obama came after 2-8 with 2008 where the
the mortgage bust the boom whatever
bubble just took off and
all these mortgages in america no income
no assets
big short the market took a massive hit
all you had to do was just to make a
couple right things for the market to
come back up
market's not going to go to 4 000. 5
000. it was only going to come up so
it's not like it was a
obama uh economics like a reagan reagan
economics that the market is going to
come back
no it was just coming in doing a couple
things and the market came back
up and not ruffling the feathers and it
came back up yeah i think obama doesn't
get credit but trump does
i'm not saying trump or obama i'm just
saying what
obama did wasn't a obama never met with
paul ryan the guy that was running his
finances
obama never sat down and had a
conversation he did it one time and and
paul asked him a couple questions they
never had a meeting again paul's like
obama never meets with me
so paul ryan in the house yes obama
wasn't a person that was about
economy that was not obama obama's not
an economy person
obama was more of a you know person that
gave you a sense of
okay he's there he's by himself he's
poised he's you know
good on the the news the way he speaks
is calm it's relaxes you when he talks
you know he doesn't kind of feel like
the end of the world
trump gets on his speaks you're thinking
we're going to go to war and we never
went to war
obama speaks you're like we're not going
to go to war and we'll roar there was
always conflicts taking place
i'm asking you under biden there's still
a lot of things that we forgot about
that were issues
a year ago brexit was still an issue
brexit is still not done china's still
an issue the tariffs are still an issue
iran is still an issue russia is still
an issue venezuela is still an issue oil
is still an issue
debt is still an issue 24 trillion
national debt is still an issue
obamacare is still an issue
tax is still an issue all of these
things just disappeared and they were
under the blank you know under the rug
because of a
pandemic this is all coming back so if
all this stuff is coming back
you're saying the next four years it's
going to go to 40k i'm saying
i i'm not saying 40k but what i am
saying is all those issues
you know go back 20 30 40 50 years those
of issues
there's always issues i don't think they
go back there's no i'm saying there's
always
30 40 50 years whether you're talking
russia where you're talking china where
you're talking communism
no 20 years china was a big issue
absolutely
nobody tweeted it was prior to that
russia was but but you were talking
russia was today you got 50 things in
the suit you're saying there's more
issues now than there were 20 by a mile
by a mile today and and at the same time
at all of that stuff
with social media the entire
conversation you had with mike has been
what how do you control your emotions to
not
add social media to it which means our
emotions are
at the highest level non-stop so it's
not you know sometime when
pre-social media we were like this oh my
gosh i can't believe what they said
and they went back to regular life you
didn't you didn't check the news
150 times a day today you check the news
150 times today it's called check on
facebook yeah
so 150 so your emotions 20 years ago
were like oh my gosh
and you come back and now it's like oh
my gosh what you you're going
to do oh we'll go go to sleep oh my
goodness that's what that's what we're
going through right now so you add all
of that stuff together
i don't know i'm just curious to know
what's going to happen over the next
four years closer to 40
are we going to dip down to 25 are we
going to stay steady
are we going to print more money is it
going to be fake market going up more
stagflation
powell said he's not lowering interest
he's not raising interest rates he's
going to keep it at negative
you know zero percent which means until
2023 rates
home property value is probably going to
stay the same they're going to have to
eventually raise the interest rates when
they raise the interest rates what's
going to happen to real estate
economy has to take a hit yeah there has
to be a hit to be taken you can't go
zero percent interest rate
from powell for the next 20 years that's
fake economy
we have a fake economy so and powell
said it six months ago that he's not
raising the race until 2023 right
what does that mean until 2023 so i i
don't know i i
my guesstimation is that not a lot is
going to change
and shit's going to hit the fan in 2024
i think the next couple years is not
actually going to be
crazy i think the next couple year is
going to be relatively the same maybe
it's going to go up a little bit maybe
it's going to go down a little bit